bonjour et bienvenue dans le 7-8
week-end l'émission consacrée aux
loisirs aux idées de sorties tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
un village football va être installée à
montigny-le-bretonneux au centre sportif
pierre de coubertin au programme des
diffusions de matches sur écran géant
un tournoi de football masculin à une
zimbabwéenne nous recevons dans quelques
instants l'adjoint au maire à michel
crottin exposition au focus sur eric
vernay ce qui expose à la commanderie
des templiers d'elancourt jusqu'au 23
juillet tous les détails sur cet
événement à suivre dans ce magazine
sport les templiers d'elancourt fête ce
samedi leur 30e anniversaire pour
l'occasion un barbecue des
démonstrations de cheerleaders et des
matchs seront organisés le programme
complet dans ce magazine avec l'une des
organisatrices de cette journée laurent
fournier et puis coup de projecteur sur
la programmation de la semaine dans les
salles obscures en nous irons au ciné
cette deal en cours avec la
programmation du ciné 7 et de l'udc beau
quand on commence ce magazine par un
rendez-vous à village football va être
installée à montier bretenoux au centre
sportif pierre de coubertin à l'occasion
de l'euro de football
au programme des diffusions de matches
sur écran géant un tournoi de football
masculin pour nous parler de cet
événement nous recevons sur ce plateau
l'adjoint au maire à la vie sportive
michel creton bonjour je alors pourquoi
organiser cet événement a menti en
bretagne écoutez c'est un événement qui
que nous avons organisé déjà faim depuis
très longtemps puisque dès l'attribution
par l'afa la france de l'euro 2016 nous
avions déjà idée d'organiser quelque
chose est en fait le projet a mûri et
nous avons nous sommes arrivés
aujourd'hui un projet qui est un projet
d'envergure dans lequel on vous ont
souhaité faire favoriser un petit peu
toutes les générations de personnes
habitant la ville et de faire travailler
un petit peu tous les tous les services
de la mairie
il fallait obligatoirement faire cet
événement il fallait y avait une attente
vraiment de la part le populaire il y
avait à la fois il y avait une attente
effectivement mais il y avait surtout le
fait le fait aussi qu'il veut que nous
sommes ville aujourd'hui la ville a pu
sportif des yvelines et que c'était un
petit peu le nôtre challenge d'organiser
un événement est aujourd'hui cet
événement est un je pense l'un des rats
des seuls événements du sur le
département
nous en sommes très fiers et ça vous a
pris combien de temps pour tout
organiser alors l'organisation en
allemagne le dire que le projet en
lui-même date de plus d'un an est là
donc on a mis quasiment un an pour
organiser tous eu toute cette semaine de
cette semaine d'animations
ça sera une petite fan zone on peut le
dire avec la route transmission à des
matchs contre eux il va on peut dire ça
ça serait une fan zone
à la seule différence c'est que les fans
zone aujourd'hui sur découverte alors
que nous faut nous ferons les diffusions
de match à l'intérieur je pense qu'on a
bien fait puisque la météo
malheureusement nous est pas tout à fait
savoir pour l'instant
et donc pour des problèmes de sécurité
aussi obligés de nous mettre à
l'intérieur donc ce sera à l'intérieur
du gymnase pierre de coubertin
et quand même personnes peuvent être
accueillies elle voit qu environ pas
curan milliers de personnes amis et
personnes au niveau sécurité je suis
obligé de vous poser à la question au
niveau sécurité quelles seront les
mesures alors il ajouté nous avaient
fortement tout à fait nous avons nous
avons d'abord nous avons travaillé donc
avec la préfecture ont travaillé avec
les services de sécurité
nous aurons des personnes qui seront
chargées de la sécurité donc des
fouilles à voir le
à l'entrée tout est en fait ça répond
aux critères aujourd'hui qui sont
demandées dans le cadre sera ce que des
contraintes aujourd'hui que nous avons
d'organiser des événements même si ce
sont dans des endroits clos il n'y aura
pas que la retransmission de matchs il y
aura également des des tournois ce
seront des tournois amicaux ça se
passera comment alors tout à fait l'an
il ya déjà vous parliez tout à l'heure
de tournoi masculin mais on nous avons
quand même en démarrage d'un tournoi
féminin bien avant demain matin nous
avons un tournoi féminin auquel
participeront d'ailleurs une équipe de
notre ville jumelle denton qui sont des
jeunes filles un tournoi dans le
tournant final avec trois autres trois
autres équipes de des yvelines
donc le bora qui sera permettront de
démontrer aussi la qualité du football
féminin
et puis donc une épreuve qui aura lieu
donc le 2 mai après midi qui est en
route vers leur vers l'euro donc il à
qui était destiné à tous les jeunes qui
veulent y participer c'est ouvrir là on
attend 3 400 400 jeunes qui peut y
participer
et puis le dimanche donc on aura bien
évidemment le le tournoi masculin donc
un tournoi toujours pareil de jeunes
tendent encore là mais on a mis l'accent
aussi sur l'international c'est sur le
sport à la jeunesse dans le sport et
puis bien entendu le soir donc un
dimanche soir
la retransmission du match france suisse
donc sur grand écran
ce sont des événements à nico des
tournois amicaux
oui oui à un petit enjeu quand même il
ya l'enjeu d'être d'être ensemble et
puis de gérer bien sûr de gagner enfin
je pense que tout compétiteur
aujourd'hui quand il veut quand il veut
quand il joue c'est quand même pour
gagner mais ça restera quand même très
amicale il y aura également une soirée 0
% foot le 20 juin je crois le labour a
rejoint donc le lundi le lundi on a
choisi effectivement cette date là
puisqu'il y avait encore des matchs
avant transmission donc pour ce sont
pour tous ceux qui aujourd'hui sont
complètement
enfin on peut être une overdose de foot
et donc on accroche sacrée et de cette
soirée à toutes les personnes au ras du
cou danse alors il y aurait il y aura
des tas d'animations il y aura des
massages y aura je crois de la coiffure
il y aura il y aura de tout un tas de
réinventer les féminins pas forcément
féminin mais bon c'est vrai que ça accès
un petit peu accès féminin mais il y
aura aussi des activités auxquelles
peuvent participer
les basculeurs enfin sans s'en être des
amateurs de foot évidemment il y aura
également des animations pour les
scolaires alors les allégations ça c'est
très important puisqu'on a aussi dans ce
projet là donc je vous le disais on a
voulu mettre l'intégralité des
générations de la ville effectivement
les scolaires ils sont associés
puisqu'il y aura tout un tas
d'animations qui auront lieu entre le
lundi et le jeudi voir le vendredi matin
donc et auquel vont participer à peu
près un millier d'écoliers de montigny
dans ce qui est une très très bonne
performance qui seront des ateliers de
découverte du foot autour de autour du
foot évidemment donc avec des avec des
animateurs qui vont leur permettre et on
a des écoles qui aujourd'hui participer
activement en proposant des aussi des
des exercices ou des notamment par
exemple la cérémonie d'ouverture
nous aurons une école qui vend qui joue
venir chanter l'hymne de l'euro fin
qu'ils ont composé donc quelque chose de
très employé qui a eu un peu scolaire
avec avec le championnat d'europe
absolument donc en fait il ya eu aussi
un engouement de la part des personnes à
qui on a proposé ce projet est qui et
qui est assez extraordinaire et qui
permet qui permet de gérer deux à la
fois de créer une unité une grande
grands mouvements autour de ceux de ce
projet là et pourquoi pas organiser cet
événement sur une seule semaine et pas
sur toute la compétition
donc parce que c'est d'avancer très
difficile je crois qu'il ya une
mobilisation aussi de personnes nombreux
services de la ville ça aussi c'est
important parce qu'ils n'auront services
de la ville qui sont concernés et
c'était très difficile de les deux fers
de les mettre en activité pendant trois
semaines quatre semaines ça c'était pas
possible donc le l'idée effectivement
d'avoir de faire ça sur un cheval de
faire un événement sur une semaine ça
nous ne nous est apparu quand même
intéressant pour finir tout le monde
peut venir fera-t-il tout le monde peut
venir c'est gratuit ce sera sécurisé
bien évidemment ce sera clos donc les
enfants neveux n'auront pas de pas de
problème de perdants des enfants dans ta
gauche s'il a donc le tout et tout est
prévu pour que tout se passe dans ma
bulle
du mieux possible merci à vous les
passer sur son plateau je le rappelle
l'événement village foot à montigny
programmé ce samedi au saut samedi 18
juin au vendredi à 24 juin comme vous le
voyez à l'écran centre sportif pierre de
coubertin
coup de projecteur à présent sur une
exposition nous allons prendre à présent
la direction de la commanderie des
templiers d'elancourt une exposition à
des ricv renaissent est programmé
jusqu'au 3 juillet dans le centre
l'artiste présente douze pièces sur 200
mètres carrés autour de la thématique du
numérique un reportage de sephora namani
dix oeuvres au mouvement narrative des
images animées les créations des ricv
renaissent sont présentés à la
commanderie des templiers
architecte de formation eric vernay se
fascine pour le cinéma depuis son plus
jeune âge ou plus exactement pour la
dimension temporelle mise en images par
le procédé cinématographique
je suis dit je vais essayer de faire un
projecteur qui serait fait que pour un
film en quelques sortes
et puis le projecteur lui même ce serait
une sculpture et puis le film ferait
partie du projecteur en quelque sorte et
l'ensemble fine projecteurs ce serait
une sculpture à part entière et se
serait fait juste pour ce film là alors
j'ai commencé à réfléchir à cette idée
là et j'en suis venu à faire des
sculptures avec du temps à l'intérieur
c'est à dire des choses qui bougent en
quelque sorte comme au cinéma
parmi ces objets temporel comme il les
appelle se distingue une oeuvre réalisée
en hommage à epicure philosophes de
l'antiquité qui eut l'intuition géniale
des atomes à l'origine de toute vie
organique
il ya donc des petites billes sur un sur
un plateau qui lorsque l'on n'avance
près de l'oeuvre se met en mouvement
elle s'entrechoquent
elles produisent un bruit et en même
temps il ya notre image qui se dessinent
sur l'écran qui est derrière comme si
c'étaient ces petites billes
représentait donc les atomes
constitutifs de ce don ce don en effet
la plupart des installations cinétique
visuel et sonore dérivés renaissent sont
mis en mouvement par le spectateur ou
des logiques auto générative une
exposition originale et interactive
un mode sport à présent les templiers
d'elancourt le club de football local
fêtera ses 30 ans ce samedi pour nous
parler de cette animation il y aura une
grande fête j'ai oublié de préciser avec
notamment à des cheerleaders et des
matchs de flag pour nous parler de cet
événement nous recevons sur ce plateau
l'organisatrice l'une des organismes
organisatrice de l'événement laurie
fonnier bonjour alors pourquoi organiser
cet événement tout simplement parce que
voilà trente ans il pense que ça se
marque ça fait c'est quand même 30
belles années fallait aussi satisfaire
tous nos anciens qui faisait partie à la
base des cormorans parce qu'avant les
temps qui étaient les cormorans
donc il fallait voilà marquer le coup et
satisfaire toutes tous les anciens et
les nouveaux des templiers non le cas
mais vous pensez que les templiers aller
fêter leur compte en un jour art moi ça
fait pas longtemps que je fais partie
des templiers mais je pense que c'est
quelque chose quand même qu'ils quittent
enfin qui reste à marquer et je pense
que c'est quelque chose qui doit être
qui doit se fêter après savoir si le
club allait tenir trente ans je pense
enfin personne peut s'en douter
réellement compte de l aventure c'est
une très belle aventure et cette journée
comment va se dérouler expliquez-nous le
programme alors il ya plusieurs
plusieurs choses qui s'organise tout au
long de la journée on a notamment un
flag qui
qui s'organise de 10h à 13h qui est
ouvert à tous moyennant 1 euro 50 pour
ceux qui n'ont pas de licence au club je
rappelle américain avec des petits
drapeaux c'est ça non équipés donc on ne
se blesse pas exactement se blesse pas
donc c'est vraiment accessible à tout le
monde toutes catégories
tout le monde peut participer voilà et
donc il y aura également des
démonstrations sur l'île il ya également
des démonstrations de cheerleaders donc
vers 15h à peu près qu'un petit show des
seniors et des juniors pour pour animer
tout ça donc le mélange entre le sport
tout est l'animation tout à fait gratuit
c'est gratuit toute la journée c'est
gratuit on met à disposition des
barbecues alors par contre les gens
doivent ramener a effectivement de quoi
manger etc
le club prévoit quelques boissons
tout est gratuit même les animations
gonflables en rapport avec le football
américain sont gratuites non sévère à
tout le monde au niveau des cheerleaders
c'est ce que vous avez préparé des
chorégraphies particulière sur cette
journée en fait le pack hot chargeur
rappelle exactement alors en fait on va
préparer on a surtout préparé toutes nos
corps et qu'on avait étudié pendant tout
le long de l'année qu'on a présenté au
match et c'est vrai que c'est un moyen
de montrer aux joueurs
nos chorégraphies qui eux ne les voit
pas quand c'est la mi-temps vu qu'ils
sont forcément dans les vestiaires donc
ça peut permettre à tout le club de
montrer un peu notre travail tout au
long de l'année et c'est aussi
l'occasion peut-être de montrer le
football américain et le cheerleading
toute personne qui ne connaîtraient pas
du tout ce sport maintenant c'est
l'objectif aussi c'est de ramener quand
même pas mal de mon pour faire découvrir
ce sport à la fois le football américain
mais qui commence à être de plus en plus
médiatisé de plus en plus connu est
également le cheerleading qui reste
encore trop trop d'inconnues à mon beauf
vous pensez que ce type d'événement peut
aider c'est le sport je penserai ouais
je pense parce que c'est un communicant
même pas mal dessus
on a quand même 120 invités pour samedi
juste pour une journée donc c'est quand
même pas mal
et puis ça parle quand même beaucoup via
les réseaux sociaux d'autres réseaux
sociaux pardon donc je pense que ça peut
être ça peut ramener pas mal de noms il
ya des inscriptions suite à cette fête
parce qu'on l'organisé tous les ans
cette année c'est la 30e au 30e
anniversaire mais qui ont voulu
organiser tous les ans est ce qu'il ya
des inscriptions suite à cet événement
je pense que les gens lambda rives et
tous deux suisses un jour de renom sur
une fiche pour s'inscrire
alors
on ne prend pas d'inscription ce jour là
spécialement après je pense que ça
ramène quand même pas mal de monde et
on fait de toute façon toutes les
licences lors du lors du forum des
associations en septembre
mais quoi qu'il arrive ça ramène
toujours des nouvelles personnes d'une
nouvelle tête et ça fait toujours
plaisir à voir
merci à vous l'aurez fournier merci je
le rappelle aux téléspectateurs
l'événement est programmée ce samedi au
complexe sportif europe 1 il encourt à
partir de 10h merci à vous on passe
maintenant à notre rubrique biologique
si vous allez au parc zoologique de
thoiry ce week-end vous aurez peut-être
la chance de voir l'une des stars de cet
euro 2016 en france
harangue le warrant l'animal donne les
pronostics des matches de l'équipe de
france
à chaque rencontre des bleus il avait
notamment pronostiqué la victoire de la
france contre la roumanie à pascal
josèphe pour le montage il sera peut
être l'une des stars de cet euro 2016 à
englos var en sept ans a été désigné par
le parc zoologique de thoiry pour
pronostiquer les résultats des matchs de
l'équipe de france pendant la
compétition
en fait on lui propose trois gammes elle
avec
le drapeau de chaque équipe plus
l'option match nul et dans chaque gamme
elle donc on met une petite friandise
c'est à dire une souris donc on fait en
sorte que les gamelles soit équidistante
y'a pas de gamelles plus facile à
atteindre que l'autre harangue a été
choisi pour ses mensurations deux
sportifs 2 m 20 pour 40 kg de muscles si
on le sort dans son enclos extérieur on
peut le voir en fait faire le tour du
propriétaire rapidement ces animaux sont
capables quand même de faire des pointes
en course à 20 km/heure après avoir
pronostiqué la victoire de la france
contre la roumanie lors du premier match
le spécialiste à sang froid avait prédit
un match nul contre l'albanie
une prédiction exacte jusqu'à la 90e
minute et l'ouverture du score d'antoine
griezmann
les bleus l'emportent finalement 2-0
la seule chose en fait c'est qu'on avait
oublié de lui spécifier qu'il y avait
aussi les arts il fallait tenir compte
des arrêts de jeu et donc lui il avait
pronostiqué match nul ce qui a été le
cas jusqu'au 90 minutes de temps
réglementaire
donc je pense qu'on peut l'excuser pour
sa 1re ans tentera de corriger cette
erreur de débutant ce week-end pour le
match de la france contre la suisse
le château de breteuil situe à choisel
dans la vallée de chevreuse propose des
visites contées tous les jours sur les
célèbres contes de perrault dans son
château pour nous parler de la structure
nous recevons sur ce bateau jean mimi à
charolles administrateur du château de
breteuil bonjour bonjour alors est-ce
que vous pouvez nous rappeler l'histoire
du château de breteuil pour été
spectateur qui ne connaîtraient pas
encore ce site alors que l'histoire du
château il a été construit il ya quatre
siècles au début du xviie siècle la fin
du règne d'henri iv et depuis quatre
siècles le château est resté dans la
même famille c'est toujours transmis
dans la même famille sans jamais être
vendus ce qui permet d'avoir dans cette
visite de châteaux et un vrai une vraie
vision de l'histoire de france à travers
l'histoire d'une famille et c'est ce que
l'on veut reconstituer grâce au
personnage de cire du musée grévin qui
rendent cette visite plus ludique et
bien nous retraçons les grands faits de
la famille à travers l'histoire de
france et combien de visiteurs viennent
tous les ans nous devrions environ 120
mille visiteurs par an nous sommes le
premier château des yvelines en terme de
fréquentation
après versailles bien sûr qui est hors
compétition beaucoup beaucoup d'enfants
environ 60 % d'enfants beaucoup viennent
avec leur école bien sûr mais beaucoup
viennent également avec leurs parents je
breteuil étant vraiment le château idéal
pour une sortie en famille je le disais
tout à l'heure il y a des comptes des
comptes présenté au château de breteuil
à ce que vous ne vous présentez comme il
ya deux scènes alors il y a huit scènes
de compte qui sont répartis dans les
dépendances du château
donc en plus de la visite historique
dont je vous parlais à l'instant il ya
tout ce parcours féerique vous allez
rencontrer le petit chaperon rouge la
belle au bois dormant le petit poucet
barbe bleue dans la salle de chasse
également nous en avons quatre sur les
huit qui sont en son et lumière donc
avec des animations c'est beaucoup plus
interactif et c'est un thème que nous
nous améliorons année après année et
les comptes à breteuil sont présents à
la fois sous cette forme de scènes de
compte les gens se promènent librement à
leur rythme et ils vont voir ces
différentes scènes
l'autre forme c'est ce sont les
conteuses les conteuses qui à 16h30 les
week-ends raconte pendant une heure
trois histoires de charles perrault
elles choisissent au début de leurs les
histoires qu'elles vont raconter je ne
peux pas vous le donner à l'avancé qui
petit suspense en fonction des tranches
d'âge parfois elles peuvent moduler leur
compte commencer par des comptes qui ne
font pas trop peur et finir par un conte
comme barbe bleue par exemple qui fait
un peu peur aux enfants à 100 là les
plus jeunes peuvent éventuellement
partir donc tout ça plaît beaucoup aux
parents aux grands-parents et bien sûr à
tous les enfants
toutes les générations confondues ont
été bercés par ses comptes
il y aura un compte aux jardins leurs
différents dans le mois de juin là il ya
une spécificité effectivement pour les
quatre dimanches du mois de juin nous en
reste deux dimanche 18 donc après demain
nous aurons un compte
au verger avec des histoires de fruits
et dimanche 20
26 nous en avons fait du potager voilà
avec des histoires de fruits de légumes
mais tout ça toujours autour de
l'histoire de perrault voilà donc il ya
toujours un lien avec charles perrault
mais une thématique donnée les fleurs
les fruits les légumes et c'est pendant
le mois de juin ça ce sont des contes
spécialité on peut le dire tout à fait
dans une formule un peu il exactement
puisqu'ils sont d'abord si le temps le
permet ils sont racontées en extérieur à
l'ombre des pommiers s'il fait chaud
si jamais il pleut bien sûr nous avons
des endroits abrités pour que les
spectateurs soit à l'abri et nous allons
souvent entre 150 et 200 chaque dimanche
et la conteuse et les costumes et à
chaque fois la conteuse son costume les
week-ends effectivement ça fait partie
du folklore et du décor et elles sont
très très professionnel elles sont
conteuse de formation et elles savent
vraiment dynamiser la foule
c'est un one man show mais c'est comme
s'il y avait plusieurs personnes sur
scène c'est pour quel public c'est pour
les plus tôt pour les petits ou les
grands peuvent aussi se mêler à ses
comptes
c'est pour les petits mais les grands
adore les grands à grains d'or parce que
les grands ont de toute façon été bercé
par et ses histoires
tout le monde connaît l'histoire du
petit poucet tout le monde connaît
cendrillon et ça amuse énormément les
parents de se replonger dans leur
enfance comme ceci et puis de voir leurs
enfants leur propre aux enfants
s'émerveiller devant la découverte de
tel ou tel compte on va parler la
nouveauté de cette année là la nouveauté
là nous alors il ya deux nouveautés je
vais assez rapidement sur la première la
nouveauté c'est le très beau mobilier
d'époque louis 15 qui est maintenant mis
en place dans l'appartement des milliers
de breteuil la marquise du châtelet un
très beau mobilier en bois doré
avec des tapisseries d'aubusson qui
représente les fables de la fontaine
là aussi c'est très ludique et vous a
également dit table voilà la grande
nouveauté c'est le retour de la table de
breteuil tape gisements voilà vous avez
le plateau de la table à taux sur
laquelle il ya 128 pierres semi
précieuses des bois pétrifiés également
c'est une table dans l'original vient
d'être vendu au louvre et nous avons
offert une magnifique réplique
la réplique est arrivé au château la
semaine dernière c'est bluffant
tellement l alcool la à l'original et
nous sommes ravis de retrouver cette
table bijoux dans le circuit de la
visite du château pour pouvoir expliquer
à nos visiteurs le rôle diplomatique qui
a joué le baron de breteuil sous louis
saez pour mettre fin à une guerre qui
menace d'embraser toute l'europe
centrale c'est le cadeau qu'il a reçue
en ayant été médiateur de paix donc
cette table pourrait s'appeler la table
de l'europe puisqu'elle a vraiment mis
fin à un conflit européen en 1779
elle s'appelle la table de breteuil et
je vous invite vraiment venir pour avoir
ce week-end a fait tout à fait merci à
vous dépasser sur ce plateau on vous
souhaite d'avoir beaucoup de monde ce
week-end et que la magie opère à nouveau
auprès la conteuse merci beaucoup merci
à vous on passe maintenant notre
rubrique cinéma
comme chaque semaine un programmateur
des divines nous présente son coup de
coeur aujourd'hui nous partons au ciné 7
des encours le responsable du cinéma à
l'ugb au camp nou représente son coup de
coeur le coup de coeur du ciné cette
semaine une fois n'est pas coutume c'est
un film cubain qui s'appelle xala une
enfance cubaine qui est proposée sur nos
écrans version originale donc c'est un
très beau film rare parce que cinéma
cubain on connaît pas beaucoup de
réalisateurs cubain on sait que c'est un
pays qui est en train de sourire qui est
en train de se modifier qui est en train
de modifier son mode de vie son mode de
fonctionnement qui s'ouvre à
l'international etc
et là on assiste à une histoire très
réaliste très bien joué par un jeune
acteur cubain qui est un peu délaissé sa
mère est défaillante et c'est lui qui
pourvoit en fait aux besoins de la
famille en élevant des chiens de combat
voilà j'en dis pas plus je vous laisse
découvrir le film c'est une petite perle
les critiques sont dithyrambiques si
vous ouvrez la presse cinéma vous verrez
éblouissante ses terres etc
c'est vraiment à découvrir dans nos
salles sur nos écrans cette semaine
je voulais aussi faire un petit focus
sur le cycle martin scorsese
puisque vous pourrez assister si vous
vous intéressez à se garer au grand
réalisateur qui est martin scorsese
dimanche à 17h30 à une conférence animée
par écart de munoz qui viendra nous
parler de l'oeuvre de scorsese et vous
assisterez à 18h30 à la projection en
version originale sous-titrée français
bien évidemment des nerfs à vif
un des films de martin scorsese voilà
pour cette semaine on passe à présent à
l'avis des téléspectateurs sur les
sorties de la semaine dans les salles
obscures
c'est un thriller assez haletant bien
tourné l'histoire est assez classique
mais c'est bien joué s'est fait avoir
c'est un très bon film banal quand koné
beigbeder sur la butte ses livres c'est
tout à fait lui c'est très bien c'est
dans le monde du makila
c'est un peu pourri mais bon mais il
faut aller le voir surtout pour la femme
et on termine ce magazine par un rendez
vous que vous pouvez aller suivre sur tv
fil 78 le championnat inter collèges de
match d'improvisation théâtrale de saint
quentin en yvelines est programmée ce
vendredi soir à 20h30 et ce samedi à
14h30 sur notre chaîne
ce soir vous retrouverez les deux
demi-finales et la finale avec les
collèges lui le village est courbé de
trappes albert einstein de manier la moe
et alexandre dumas de maurepas c'est la
fin de ce site huit week-ends merci
d'avoir suivi je vous retrouve lundi
prochain pour les 7-8 sport très bon
week-end sur tv fil 78